here's some advice when visiting  budapest  look up  i mean way up  there  is  this great big story was made possible  by budapest spice of europe  budapest is bursting with architecture  and some of these very buildings are  topped with these special tiles  all thanks to one hungarian company  [Music]  the company has been making building  tiles for over one hundred fifty years  the marvison  budapest's skyline became full of bright  and colorful roofs during the  architectural boom buildings like the  museum of applied arts built in 1896  the state geological institute topped  with its bright blue tiles  followed by the saint lazlow church  and of course the famous great market  hall  you know  the tiles on order  so next time you're in budapest why  don't you look up and see what the birds  see  [Music]